we were being told that inflation is
transitory and actually there's no way
it was transitory we were all
experiencing at you know toilet paper
shooting up the roof in terms of how
expensive toilet paper was getting and
other items we were seeing shrink
flation all these other elements were
coming into the mix that was not being
reported and we felt we needed to track
that and so you know it's it's no long
you know shrink flation how do you track
sh shrink flation you know the different
size packets and you were alluding it to
it is it with salt or without out Sal
right ingredients get extracted sizes
get smaller prices may stay the same but
the size is smaller how do you take that
into account in in in a whole mix and
and so those are all elements that we
challenge our analytics team day and day
out to sort of filter out and wait
accordingly all right guys bang bang
I've got stuff on here uh I thought a
great place to start is inflation is
obviously something that everyone
debates there's the kind of government
statistics they say in inflation got
high about 9% and then it came down a
little bit uh there's people on the
internet who say no you Liars it went
way higher than that you guys are all
lying to us and I'm not getting to keep
up with inflation because it's rising
too quickly why is it so heavily debated
shouldn't this just be math 1 plus one
equals two why can people not agree on
what the actual inflation rate is well
you'd think so right but um yeah thanks
for having me back by the way and and
glad people are paying attention and and
interested in the topic in
uh totally underestimated how big a
topic it was going to be and and is
currently still um but that said you
know if you think about it it's there's
a scorecard for an economy is generally
viewed as one metric and that is
inflation right people just look at how
is the economy performing performing and
that is inflation and if you go back and
look at who calculates inflation how is
it calculated and what is the
methodology all of those elements are
under the same house right so the same
people that actually you know perform
the economy or manage the economy are
the same ones driving the scorecard are
the same ones driving the actual
methodology and how to score an economy
and then going to collect the data that
feeds into the score so too many you
know mixed and conflict of interests I
think involved in that whole process and
so that's why we really felt that number
one we need automate that process number
two is we need to provide transparency
immutability to it and then ultimately
get a independent source for
inflation now if the inflation number is
wrong the CPI number that the government
is using where does that have the
biggest impact is that just like it
poorly informs Central Bankers in terms
of monetary policy decisions does it
poor poorly inform consumers uh in terms
of their purchasing decision does it
poorly inform investors where do you see
the biggest negative impact so biggest
impact is obviously inflation is is a
hidden tax right I mean ultimately your
the value of the money that you've saved
gets debased so we lose in terms of
purchasing power and that has a
significant impact the other element
think about it governments today around
the world have some $4.4 trillion dollar
in inflationary linked bonds these are
loans that they give out um and ask
people to give them money and guarantee
those loans against inflation Plus
interest on top of that ultimately the
interest is lower because they're
guaranteeing inflation so in real terms
which is an e economic um you know name
for actually saying we are above
inflation we're out performing inflation
and ultimately they're calculating
inflation and then giving you an
interest rate out associated with that
4.4 trillion dollars that's quite a
significant number and that has a
significant impact that until true
flation it has always been taken for GR
as granted you know the numbers are
again provided by the BLS and we can
issue 4.4 trillion um and and our view
is you know we need to change that and
have an independent source to accurately
reflect how investors get
rewarded when you see um them going into
the stores right the uh Bureau of Labor
Statistics sends people physically into
a store with a tablet and they got to go
and look for the exact soup with no salt
right make sure that they get it correct
um you all are taking this automated
approach explain like where are you
finding the data how are you making sure
that the data you're you're using as an
input is accurate uh and then how often
are you checking to see whether the data
has changed or not so there we check
every every day or I mean in some cases
you don't really need to check every day
so we check every week in some of the
bigger cases we check every month so we
come in all different time intervals um
for groceries I mean we break down
contrast to the government that c that
breaks it down into to six categories we
have 12 subcategories that we track the
data in we have 18 million items versus
80,000 items so ultimately a significant
larger um portfolio of items that we
track we have three price feeds per item
all of that ultimately we get updated
through multiple different channels they
can come through actually the grocery
stores which are sharing their sort of
receipts at the teller you know sort of
U Point of Sales so we get that
information we get it through iot
devices we get it through barcode
readers we get it um through API feeds
from the various Outlets uh from car
gurus uh from from Zillow from Trulia
you name it sort of all the different
sites and more and more so we're also
getting it and including sort of
synthetic assets associated with real
world assets into the mix so we get just
a different perspective of how prices
are changing I mean the reason why we
got into this in the first place places
we were being told that inflation is
transitory and actually there's no way
it was transitory we were all
experiencing at you know toilet paper
shooting up the roof in terms of how
expensive toilet paper was getting and
other items we were seeing shrink
flation all these other elements were
coming into the mix that were not being
reported and we felt we needed to track
that and so you know it's it's no long
you know shrink flation how do you track
shr shrink flation you know the
different size packets and you were
alluding it to it is it with salt or
without salt right ingredients get
extracted sizes get smaller uh prices
may stay the same but the size is
smaller how do you take that into
account in in in a whole mix and and so
those are all elements that we challenge
our analytics team day and day out to
sort of filter out and and wait
accordingly now when you see that data
coming in uh the next thing is you've
got to have a methodology of how you
actually calculate it one of the big
controversies or highly debated
components of CPI is is that they
created this basket and the basket has
different weightings of the goods and
what is the basket how does it work they
try to explain it but I think people
have a lot of questions and then it also
doesn't get at the point that like maybe
you have different inflation experience
than I do based on what I buy and so how
do you think about the methodology do
you have a basket how are you doing that
and then how do you also think about
personalized inflation and and maybe
trying to measure that yeah I mean we we
have a we take a census based approach
number one Number Two the government
takes a panel-based approach so the way
the government does it is they take a
thousand households they rotate those
households every month and see how those
households are spending and extrapolate
that across the market we try to
actually aggregate real spending power
based on credit card data based on
consumer patterns we've actually
launched on TR inflation. calulator you
can actually go and calculate your
personal inflation we have a couple of
profiles you can find a profile close to
you to simplify by the input process um
and we will be launching very soon an
anonymous credit card integration where
you can just tie your credit card to the
account and constantly be updated based
on your spending pattern what are you
seeing over a course period of time what
is inflation and how is that impacting
you um on a personal level and and so
those are things that we're trying to
add and aggregate more and more
real-time data from the actual users
themselves in terms of how they're
spending it and then be able to
personalize it into types of individuals
or different categories Urban rural uh
you know um yeah High you know Tech
worker you know a sort of factory worker
um different ranges um of you know
Suburban family sort of um and and and
things like that when we look at suburbs
vers urban areas one of the things that
is also happening is uh there seems to
be government spending which may be at
odds with monetary policy so the FED is
tightening uh but politicians are
stuffing liquidity into the market and
so even when you just look at the fed's
balance sheet or you look at uh interest
rates you're like oh inflation should be
coming down aggressively if you actually
go and you look at some of the
month-over-month inflation numbers it's
telling a different story than the
year-over-year numbers and so how do you
start to break out some of these nuances
Suburban vers Urban you know month over
month versus year over year and really
try to get at like what is likely
happening with inflation today and how
will that affect my portfolio or how
will that affect the goods that I'm
going to
buy well there are two elements there's
the structural side of things that that
are that we've seen and experience
through the whole covid and and now sort
of the the attempt to sort of become
bring do more onshoring right as we
bring more and more of the manufacturing
onshore um Etc that's a what we call
sort of structural changes and then
there are the seasonal changes right
where you see sort of spending patterns
around the Christmas time frame around
around the summer holidays all of these
things have an impact on pricing and
inflation um you know we just saw
December numbers be announced in January
we're coming up next week to the January
numbers we see the January numbers come
down over the December numbers
significantly um but we're also going to
see a a a a catchup right so it takes
time for businesses to adjust their
pricing so in some cases and and it's
not necessarily ging you know they've
been they've experienced inflation
they've had you know more salary
increases they've had cost of goods go
up uh supply chain costs go up etc those
take a time time to filter through and
then actually before the pricing hits
the shelves it just takes time and that
might see coming back uh inflation
coming back in the next couple of months
um and and so that that's sort of one
aspect that we're sort of looking at and
and sort of how we sort of see Trends
happening I'd say that's yeah now how
can people use this alternative
inflation measurement right one of the
things is you got to get the data right
the second thing is you got to get
legitimacy in the eyes of certain people
uh and then the third thing is it can be
implemented do you expect this to be a
replacement do you expect this to be a
complimentary data source to CPI how do
you expect people to use it well I mean
CPI is so entrenched we don't see that
us us really having a big D at the
moment the advantage we've had is a
mistrust in the numbers that are being
reported by the CPI uh we like to view
ourselves as a complimentary data to be
able to hold accountable the um people
that are actually doing the b or the
people at the BLS actually calculating
um government related uh metrics there
is so entrenched you have the whole
federal system statistical system that
actually has some 13 different
departments that are aggregating data
across different different categories um
and they then all sort of report
overlapping numbers to some extent and
what we're seeing is they don't actually
even integrate with each other how can
they use modern systems to be able to
help them be more efficient have less
headcount operationally be super lean
report fast in real time no more with
stale data all of those things we're
trying to sort of help and and provide
um uh you know it's just an alternative
source of Truth for this
ultimately um our goal is when will
people want to issue or when will
institutions want to issue a a loan or a
bond tied to true flation I mean that
would be sort of really a a a a stamp of
approval for what we're working on and
what we've been you know sort of working
the last three years on our methodology
by the way is super transparent you can
go to the website download the
methodology everybody that has reviewed
our methodology has been super impressed
by the accuracy the breakdown the the
level of professionalism that has gone
into that as along with that
transparency and and apparently our
website doesn't reflect that that easily
but you have different types of users
people that just want to come and see
and quickly see the metrics and then you
have people that really want to analyze
the details and the data so we had to
accommodate for both
constituents what's the response been
from reporters like I find that they
have a big uh hand in pushing a
narrative um most of them do a great job
they you know are trying to kind of
figure it out just along with everyone
else uh are they starting to use true
flation more often or are they still
stuck on CPI as the the say all be all
today's episode is brought to you by
espresso the maker of the world's
thinnest portable display now listen up
if you're like me you feel like you are
at a command center when you sit down at
your desk I got a gazillion tabs open
and different windows for different
activities ities there's my web browser
my text messages I've slack open and I
got a Notes app I normally work on a
desktop and it can be very very
productive but everything falls apart
the second I leave my desk if I'm
traveling if I go to a coffee shop to do
some work or just want to work from the
kitchen table my laptop doesn't have
enough screen space I lose my command
center and my productivity falls off a
cliff it's a major problem but this is
where espresso comes in they have a
portable screen that is so beautiful
that you think Steve Jobs came back from
the dead to create it the thing is
incredibly light it comes with a nice
stand and the user interface is so easy
that I figured out how to do it in less
than 3 minutes if you listen to this
podcast you know that's not an easy feat
so the espresso team and I we became
friends I got to know them cuz I really
like the product and those screens they
now want to offer them to any fan of the
podcast so we struck a little deal
here's how it works anyone who listens
to this podcast can go to
us.
P.O or that's too confusing just go
click the link in the description if you
go to espresso's website they've got a
brand new offer there sitting for you
you get a little discount and you'll get
a beautiful screen trust me I use mine
every day you'll love the espresso
screen and I think it'll make you more
productive go check them out today by
clicking on the link in the description
no I think we're seeing it grow more and
more I mean we see different types of
media right so um the right I mean sort
of fox will then sort of always use true
flation as an alternative source of
Truth um NASDAQ the financial services
sector will use tration and always like
to hear trl's opinion but it's more just
let's get a different opinion let's have
a different perspective and we
definitely provide a different
perspective um and and the people that
want to take it serious and and sort of
front run the BLS numbers um they will
use true flation and the people that
want to just wait and see what um the
outcome is of the BLS they will have
their alternative sources to try and
front run it themselves um uh with
whatever means that they possibly can
and when I say front run I don't mean it
in a negative sense they're just trying
to predict the outcome and what they try
to do is then trade on the in you know
yield um associated with a lot of these
interest rates inflation linked
bonds when you see the um uh inflation
in the United States take off and then
come crashing back down um at the same
time we have tons of Bank Executives and
others saying that uh a recession is
incoming but we also see the Federal
Reserve chairman Drome Powell on 60
Minutes the other night saying basically
everyone chill out you know it's okay
yeah um are there other data points that
you all think that you can start to get
at that can help people be better
informed outside of just the inflation
numbers yeah I mean we're trying to get
much more data we actually bring in what
we call leading economic indicators
which influence the future pricing of uh
inflation so that can be the price of
Commodities uh the raw materials that go
into let's say uh EV Vehicles right so
all of a sudden I have copper I have
nickel I have Palladium I have Platinum
all of these elements go into the
battery that's required to power EV
Vehicles if we believe that EV Vehicles
is the next element how is that going to
impact the pricing of EV Vehicles how do
we do that in the housing market the
price of of of of of wood uh in meat
groceries if we still want to eat meat
on the table how does that impact the
price supply chain weather all of these
elements how can we identify patterns
and then get into the more
predictability associated with it we're
really comfortable today to go three
months out into predict predicting
inflation um and and one month is is
sort of automated now and and three
months we still need a bit of human
influence to identify some Trends and be
able to imp you know take in Black Swan
events potential Black Swan events and
then give that a waiting uh in the mix
uh manually at the moment but we're
trying to automate a lot of that let's
talk about about personalized inflation
and you guys have this new product
that's coming out in terms of being able
to uh essentially say hey here's what I
spend money on like how much is
inflation affecting me what is that
product really going to do and and how
does it work so I mean it's it's it's
basically you you you go on you go on to
the site uh you choose your demographic
are you an urban professional a retired
senior a Suburban family and then it
prepopulates based on the average
spending uh the income that you get in
in that and you can adjust each one of
those elements so if you find your
spending is a bit more or a bit less you
can just adjust it but everything's
pre-populated and then it just
calculates what inflation is um for your
household and then you know how does
that impact your monthly spend uh and
what is the result of that and so those
are elements that we will just automate
one thing we are announcing is uh in the
next couple of weeks we will be bringing
out a Anonymous credit card integration
so you can just give us your credit card
details and you'll earn for sharing some
of that points for sharing some of that
Insight um and you will then be able to
then actually just continue to spend
with that credit card and that data will
be updated anonymously on your account
so that you can then actually go and see
without having to populate anything how
you're actually spending it and where
inflation is impacting you most is it in
your rent if you pay rent with credit
card though um but if you're spending in
Transportation on your utilities on
Healthcare uh
Etc when you see the um spending on my
credit card yep can I actually predict
if I buy this now versus if I buy it in
you know 90 days and and I'm assuming
consumer goods may be easier than some
of these other things but um you know
food I need the food now I I can't not
eat for 90 days but uh on the on some of
these consumer goods um is that possible
at some point at some point we'll be
able to do that up one month out I don't
think 90 days yet we don't confident
with that but we'll be able to give you
30 days out in terms of what the price
of these items will how will they evolve
over the next 30 days that we'll be able
to do um food items we update on a
weekly basis I mean generally the price
of eggs don't go up every single day
they change maybe over a weekly basis um
and things like that clothing update we
update sort of pretty much weekly as
well um clothing seems to have come down
significantly for some reason or other
um and and I mean largely due to um over
Supply from Christmas the overhang of
Christmas what has been the most
surprising thing of working on this
right I think everyone again controversy
over inflation people think that the
government data is inaccurate you now
have spent three years digging deep into
what they're doing how they're doing it
with the methodology is the data sources
U you know kind of all of the the
different inputs that go into
calculating CPI you've now built a
system that you think is at least on par
if not better could serve as as
complimentary uh component what's been
the biggest surprise yeah I mean look at
the level of Interest I mean you know we
we got immediate support from Balaji and
and and and and yourself I mean you know
sort of really to to to Really build a
professional product around this we sort
of started this as a hobby didn't
believe it let's let's go have a look
and and the level of interest just
hasn't died down I thought about a year
ago it would die down but it hasn't died
down and and people are really beginning
to trust the metrics that we're bringing
we're still here three years in you know
we're still delivering actually more and
more relevant components to this that's
been a really big surprise uh on my side
um to see how this is grown um the other
element is is is just yeah the the trust
um yeah the lack of trust the waning
trust in in institutions providing um
you know information through closed
rooms I think that's been a real big
surprise um and the growth you know the
the growth that we've experienced 8,000
unique users every month new users
coming to the site every month and that
ultimately has allowed us to then scale
up on the talent that we've got in the
team which has been really exciting to
experience as
well when you're building something like
this the aspect to me that I think is uh
most interesting is like there's
economists there are mathematicians
there are developers uh there's Business
Development how do you balance building
a team where really you have kind of um
a very hard you know kind scientific
problem to figure out but then you also
have to go build the business itself and
and it it's seems a little bit different
than maybe software where you're just
hey we write a software program
something breaks uh we can quickly you
know issue a patch and and keep going
this feels like it has more gravity to
the actual product and accuracy and
things like that so how do you go about
building that type of team to to make
sure this is
successful yeah I mean you know startup
as you know is is not easy right I mean
it it's it's pretty tough um and and
then yeah startup where you're balancing
science uh you're balancing Tech you're
balancing marketing you need
distribution you need awareness um
balancing all of those definitely not
easy we started I mean we're from a tech
standpoint we're now building out V4
right so we've constantly had to scale
adjust redevelop redeploy and all doing
that in parallel to actually running and
operating a business uh having a good
design having a good user experience
having advisors on that help us and the
support from these advisors has been
really you know Paramount to Our Success
you know from chain link to coinbase to
BAGI to yourself um and then other
macroecon economists that have really
just picked up on um what we're
providing and then pushing us hard in
terms of how are we documenting this
how's this described are we doing you
you know you should be taking this data
might be more accurate and then trying
to crowdsource the data I mean that
balance and then try to make money in
parallel right A lot of people at the
beginning questioned how are you making
money how are you making money this you
know this is already for free why do I
need another alternative Source um and
so that's been a big challenge um and I
think yeah you you pointed Us in the
right direction where to get money first
and and try to build this up and so we
started getting some customers which
helped fund the business which helped us
then scale and and and raise another
round of of investment to really
actually scale this even further myv
constant you're constantly chasing this
right you just it's a cycle when you're
going small you're starting trying to go
bigger and bigger and then you just
trying to just scale it scale it each
time and you're hunting growth all the
time and how do you lead growth how do
you motivate a team um persistently
tirelessly you know yeah my my favorite
thing that you guys were doing I think
is um you're using the tools that are
available today right and you know I
always said housing as a great example
uh you can call people on the phone and
say hey what what did you pay for rent
last month or you know what do you think
your house is worth if you sold it um
but man is it much more valuable to just
go on Zillow or you know redin or just
name your platform and see what did they
actually sell for and do it across the
country in an automated fashion with
real-time data um and constantly update
over and over and over again what is
actually happening with housing prices
nationally exactly I mean that's really
that and it was it was amazing that
nobody had actually done it and then we
actually found University so in the
housing sector we work really closely
with Penn State University who have a
whole team of students that are actually
crunching the numbers with us and
helping us optimize the metrics so that
we can stay up to nine months ahead of
where you know the government reporting
ends up right and so things like that
and I you just don't as you go in your
startup Journey you stumble upon on
individuals and and people that want to
help out introductions opportunities and
it's how you capture those opportunities
and convert them into the product that
you're building and have a win-win
scenario with the people that you're
working with they love us because we're
giving them real-time data and helping
them on the development side and we love
them because they're bringing an
economic Al aspect to how we calculate
the housing index um you know which
which is helps us just strengthen the
protocols that we have
where is the biggest risk for this not
working right as you continue to build
this out uh everyone's excited everyone
is uh uh looking forward to having an
alternative measurement that's that's
accurate but most entrepreneurs are risk
Killers so what do you see as the
biggest risk that you've got to continue
to mitigate over time I mean the risk I
mean I definitely see a bit of a
regulatory risk sort of coming in you
know sort of sense censorship oriented
right I mean you're seeing in Europe
they're already censoring you know
social media because it's a narrative
that they don't like Canada's been doing
the same thing will they do that around
something that's tying to the scorecard
of the performance or even underlying a
$4.4 trillion dollar industry um that
number one um I'm not too worried about
it today but maybe tomorrow or the day
after tomorrow uh that might be an issue
otherwise sort of um it's getting into
new markets how do I scale how do I get
more Regional uh you know that's a real
challenge there's a significant cost
to going into more local um you know the
ability to then calculate inflation
locally how do I aggregate the data how
do I crowdsource maybe even at some
point the data and the price feeds um
Etc so those are old challenges I see
riskwise I mean yeah you know it's just
running out of gas or steam or or energy
to continue to drive this but I think
you know there's such an opportunity
right now data is the new oil leveraging
AI to to really use our and evolve our
prediction capability you know those are
all tools that we need to deploy if we
don't use them I think that's another
big risk uh and challenge that we have
um trying to leverage the historical
data and get smarter at what we're doing
than you know any individual
institution when I see the United States
being slow on adopting this is there an
opportunity to go to other countries and
get them to adopt this more into um kind
of the the sophisticated professional uh
world of Economics you know monetary
policy maybe even some impact on fiscal
policy yeah for sure I mean the United
States I mean it's not slow we're you
know we're
it's I mean Australia only reports
inflation on a quarterly basis just as
an example and Canada's pretty Advanced
uh the UK is pretty advanced in terms of
systems that they've deployed to track
inflation um you know I mean
opportunities are huge when you go to
Emerging Markets I mean look at Turkey
we've been really there's a strong pull
for us to go to Turkey a strong pull to
go to Argentina now with mle in charge
over there what is the impact of his
Reign going to look like right over the
next two three years how is inflation
going to come down how is he going to
control inflation what are the impact of
his policies and his you know cutting
you know cutting of of departments and
regul
how are they going to benefit the
economy and what does that mean for
inflation in Argentina uh those are all
things that we're looking at and they
have a a significant impact largely I
mean why we focused on the US and why
the US number one the systems there are
the most are pretty advanced in terms of
data access uh number two is the US
dollar is still the currency reserve for
everybody else everybody else
experiencing inflation they go to the US
dollar right it's the facto currency
where everybody goes when they're
suffering inflation and so if the US has
inflation then there's no other currency
to go to where do I go then the only
other Resort is really I mean it becomes
Bitcoin right I mean it's really very
hard to balance that and and yeah and so
we just feel it's our you know one of
the tasks how do we educate people what
is inflation and where is it in the US
in which sector is it hitting the most
and how are people spending money the
most 20% goes into the housing right so
if the housing market goes up that has
the biggest impact in people's inflation
right as we've seen um you build this
out over three years has there been
anyone um who's just been outright this
is not going to work uh you're wasting
your time like a well-known investor uh
a well-known uh CEO just someone that is
like driving you to make sure it's
successful
yes who I mean look I mean we started
this off the first we got a lot of uh
support in the
beginning um and and you know I we tried
to raise money during um a very tight
Market uh during covid um I think I
pitched some 1,300 investors and there
were two or three that really yeah I
just really wanted to show it to them
and just we'll we'll get out there we'll
make sure this is going to be successful
and I'm just going to die trying and and
yeah we I think we've just really cut a
curve just the last four months we
really had some sort of breakthrough um
as the narrative with black rock coming
into Bitcoin with rwa becoming a
stronger narrative right now the
tokenization of everything um you know
blockchain actually being a credible
source of Technology um and so those are
all elements that played in our favor
and we're using the blockchain for
making sure that the data is immutably
locked on the blockchain and anybody can
go and verify the calculations um we're
just launching a
decentralized um solution our definitive
resource uh point where we're going to
enable across a decentralized network
the ability to actually build your own
indexes off the verified data that we've
that we actually store on the
blockchain and then my last question for
you is um as this continues to get built
things like artificial intelligence uh
have become more prominent are there
ways to use those new technologies to
reinforce even further kind of the work
that you're
doing yeah I mean predicting right
everybody wants predicting everybody
wants to read into the future so how can
we leverage technology with the granular
10year history or 12 year 15E history
that we have how can we actually
leverage all of that across not only the
pricing of items but also of the leading
economic indicators and identify
patterns Trends and then extrapolate
that that excuse me into the future uh
that's something we definitely are
trying to work on um and and we'll be
building out um yeah I mean we're still
in the early stages I mean we've just
manage to sort of aggregate all the
different data sets the different
formats the different time intervals and
then make them composable uh we're now
adding thirdparty uh data aggregators to
the mix so that their data becomes
composable and now how do we enable the
prediction associated with all of that
data around specific characteristics I I
don't need to know the whole CPI but I
may just be interested in what is
influencing the housing market and then
how can I build prediction in the
housing category how can I do that in
transportation how can I do that in the
clothing sector or the you know sort of
other elements versus overall on the
whole um CPI itself
where can we send people to find you on
the internet or if they want to learn
more about true flation either check out
the data the dashboards or potentially
become a customer go to tr.com follow us
on Twitter and those are the two main
sources where we give you updates uh we
share a lot of our information on the on
those two platforms either on our
website you can read everything on our
blog and test out our calculator um and
and let us know how we can improve it
and make it
better awesome Stefan thank you so much
for this I'm a huge fan of what you guys
are doing literally I think since the
first time I heard about it I said oh
man if they could pull that off that'd
be incredibly valuable so hopefully uh
you're well on your way to doing that
and we will definitely do this again in
the future no thank you for having me
again and thank you for your your
support I mean yeah it was really right
at the beginning you were there in Miami
I remember we were on a call and um yeah
it was super good support so thank you
for everything you've been and W you
know working with us on this journey
right it's been a interesting Journey
Back